♪ ♪
>> Sean: WITH REACTION IS THE
ONGOING KAVANAUGH NOMINATION
SAGA, PRESIDENT OF THE NEW YORK
CIVIL RIGHTS COALITION, FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE ACLU,
MICHAEL MYERS.
YOU SAW THE AD WE PLAYED LAST
NIGHT.
SINCE 1981 TO 2005, YOU WERE A
MEMBER, A HIGH-RANKING MEMBER OF
THE ACLU?
>> I WAS ON THE BOARD, I WAS
ALSO A VOTING MEMBER MOST OF
THOSE YEARS ON THE ACLU
EXECUTIVE'S COMMITTEE.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> I WAS PROUDEST OF THE ACLU
WHEN THEY RESISTED FASCISM, WHEN
THEY STOOD UP TO THE
MAMA.
NOW THEY HAVE BECOME THE MOM.
IT HAS BECOME WHAT THEY ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE.
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO STAND UP TO
THE MOB, STAND FOR FREEDOM AND
INDIVIDUAL LIBERTY, SUPPOSED TO
STAND FOR THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ASSUMPTIONS.
IT MAKES A PRESUMPTION THAT A
PERSON IS PRESUMED TO BE
INNOCENT UNLESS HE IS PROVEN
GUILTY BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT
IN TERMS OF CIVIL MATTERS, THE
PERCENT IS INNOCENT UNLESS THERE
IS A PREPONDERANCE OF THE
EVIDENCE.
>> Sean: WHAT HAPPENED,
MICHAEL?
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOUR
ORGANIZATION?
>> THE THE ACLU IS HIJACKEDY
>> THE THE ACLU IS HIJACKEDT
>> THE THE ACLU IS HIJACKEDE
LEFT.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN FREE
SPEECH ANYMORE.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN ANYTHING
OTHER THAN THE RESISTANCE.
AS OPPOSED TO RESISTING FASHION,
THEY HAVE BEEN PART OF THE
RESISTANCE MOVEMENT.
I >> Sean: DO CIVIL
LIBERTARIANS COME BACK TO WHERE
YOU WERE, OR DO YOU NOW JOIN
PEOPLE LIKE ME, WHICH I KNOW
WILL GIVE -- SEND SHOCK WAVES
THROUGH YOUR SPINE?
>> LET'S PUT IT THIS WAY.
THE ACLU HAS BECOME LIKE THE
NAACP.
ONCE YOU LOSE CONTROL OF YOUR
BOARD, ONCE YOU DO NOT HAVE
CIVIL LIBERTARIANS ON THE BOARD,
YOU DO NOT HAVE A CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION ORGANIZATION
ANYMORE.
AND YOU ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
BOTTOM-LINE LUNATICS IN TERMS OF
THE LEFT.
THEY WANT "JUSTICE" PEERED SO IF
A WOMAN ENCOURAGES A MAN, THE AC
A WOMAN ENCOURAGES A MAN, THE AS
A WOMAN ENCOURAGES A MAN, THE AT
A WOMAN ENCOURAGES A MAN, THE AO
A WOMAN ENCOURAGES A MAN, THE AN
A WOMAN ENCOURAGES A MAN, THE AI
A WOMAN ENCOURAGES A MAN, THE AS
A WOMAN ENCOURAGES A MAN, THE AE
A WOMAN ENCOURAGES A MAN, THE AO
A WOMAN ENCOURAGES A MAN, THE AF
THE ACLU.
THIS HAS NEVER BEEN A PRINCIPAL
OF CIVIL LIBERTIES.
YOU CAN'T ACCUSE SOMEONE AND
PRESUME A PERSON IS GUILTY AS
OPPOSED TO INNOCENT.
>> Sean: THERE ARE PEOPLE LIKE
YOU, ALAN DERSHOWITZ IN THIS